kilomètres heures en tgv c'est peut-être
possible avec la sncf la société de
chemin de fer tentera d'établir un
nouveau record du monde cette semaine
luz tonnes de cocaïne pure et une
quinzaine de trafiquants arrêtés c'est
une véritable usine de la drogue qui a
été découverte en collant vie saisie
spectaculaire aussi aux antilles 30
heures non-stop de document de
discussion de films et des archives sur
la seconde guerre mondiale la nuit la
plus longue comment sur notre plateau se
soit invité du 19/20 pierre louis blanc
ancien collaborateur du général de
gaulle enfin sécheresse que d'alec mason
dans plusieurs régions de france les
rationnements où les quotas d'irrigation
semble maintenant inévitable
bonsoir la sncf à des privilèges pas de
limitation de vitesse pour elle le tgv
atlantique va tenter de rouler cette
semaine à 500 kilomètres à l'heure il
battrait ainsi le record du monde qu'il
détient déjà
on imagine l'ivresse du cheminot mais
aussi les conséquences économiques d'un
tel exploit
marie-odile panijel battre son propre
record du monde la sncf relève le défi
le 5 décembre dernier le tgv atteignait
la vitesse de 482 km heure laissant loin
derrière la concurrence étrangère un
petit regret tout même ne pas avoir
atteint le seuil psychologique des 300
miles ou des 500 km heure cette semaine
les essais reprennent sur la ligne à
grande vitesse entre tours et courtalain
pour des tests d'endurance mais la sncf
ne s'en cache pas si les techniciens le
centre
rien ne les empêchera de pousser la
machine le record est à portée de rails
il faudra pourtant compter avec la météo
les fortes chaleurs ne sont pas
favorables aux exploits au delà de la
performance technologique un enjeu
économique important
la corée du sud devrait choisir avant
l'été entre le tgv français le
shinkansen japonais et l'intercity
express allemand outre sa vitesse le tgv
peut utiliser les infrastructures
existantes des avantages qui pourraient
convaincre les coréens mais aussi
américains australiens aux canadiens de
rouler français
toujours plus vite sur rail toujours
plus vite là haut le concorde ne veut
pas être en reste toujours plus vite
toujours plus haut et toujours plus loin
le super concorde c'est la nouvelle
aventure est le nouveau défi que devrait
lancer cette semaine française et
britannique
un accord sera sans doute signé mercredi
il était temps l'avion est à l'étude
depuis dix ans il pourrait voler vers
explications jean jacques peyraud dans
quelques minutes je pense mais super
concorde tarder à partir apparemment il
n'a pas décollé oui bien le concorde et
où le super concorde n'a pas décollé
j'espère qu'il le fera pendant ce
journal le cartel international de la
drogue trouve désormais sur sa route un
autre cartel policiers celui là est
efficace trois opérations spectaculaires
viennent de le confirmer en petits états
unis
selon guy trois opérations
spectaculaires en un week-end trois
opérations une véritable victoire pour
le gouvernement colombien
du jamais vu les policiers ont saisi 12
tonnes de cocaïne pure et découvert une
base arrière très importante pour les
trafiquants jérôme cathala
au départ les agents secrets infiltrés
dans les réseaux de la drogue
à l'arrivée une vaste opération
militaire dans la jungle colombienne au
sud du pays
une opération qui a commencé jeudi
dernier le résultat
le voilà douze tonnes de cocaïne saisis
valeur marchande plus de 900 millions de
dollars
malgré l'effet de surprise la plupart
des trafiquants pu s'enfuir
seuls 17 d'entre eux ont été arrêtés
deux sont morts dans les combats saisi
également quatre avions ainsi que des
explosifs et des armes
cette capitale de la drogue aujourd'hui
investie par l'armée colombienne
comportait plus de 30 pistes
d'atterrissage dont l'une longue de 2400
mètres pouvait accueillir des avions
gros porteurs et dans ses laboratoires
la pâte de coca et et transformer en
cocaïne
d'ici là marchandises étaient envoyés en
amérique centrale et aux états unis
aux etats unis justement d'autres
narcotrafiquants aussi été arrêté à
miami exactement en floride
moins spectaculaires mais sans doute
aussi important car ces sommes tentés
d'acheter plus de 100 missiles
hier ceux là même qui ont prouvé leur
efficacité en afghanistan de telles
armes peut pas battre des hélicoptères
et des avions
le projet des trafiquants assassiner le
président colombien barco enfin dans les
antilles françaises hier sur l'île de
saint-martin dernier coup porté aux
narcos aux barons de la drogue par dont
380 kg de cocaïne saisis par la police
dans un avion qui venait d'atterrir
trois succès pour les états face aux
narcotrafiquants
on assiste à une mobilisation générale
au niveau mondial et c'est d'autant plus
facile
j'allais dire pour les services de
police que nous sommes d'inscrits à
notre action dans ce contexte politique
qui est très favorable
tous ensemble nous essaierons travailler
la main dans la main pour coincer le
maximum de trafic taux qui eux aussi
sont organisés en cartel un à deux
façons de nous nous faisons fonctionner
des cartels aujourd'hui ce cartel de la
lutte anti-drogue a donc marqué des
points des points importants mais la
guerre n'est pas encore gagné c'était un
petit rappel super concordaient prêts à
décoller aux commandes sans jacques
théron voici à quoi ressemblera le super
concorde dans les bureaux d'études de
l'aérospatiale on l'appelle ac tss
avions de transport supersonique futur
il volera à peine plus vite qu'aux
concorde mais il ira deux fois plus loin
12000 km contre 6200 et emportant entre
deux et trois cents passagers
c'est à dire deux à trois fois plus que
concorde ajoutons qu'il consommera deux
fois moins de carburant et ne sera pas
plus bruyant à l'atterrissage et au
décollage d'un avion classique
seule inconnue mais de taille les
moteurs il en aura quatre mais il reste
à les concevoir la snecma et rolls royce
qui avait construit celui de concorde il
ya 20 ans travaille déjà sur ce mouton à
cinq pattes qui devra être à la fois
puissants économes en carburant et
respectueux de la fameuse couche d'ozone
il n'est pas exclu que pour le mettre au
point les européens s'associent à des
partenaires américains japonais et même
soviétique
tous en effet doivent répondre aux mêmes
défis l'explosion du trafic aérien long
courrier en 15 ans le nombre des
passagers a été multiplié par trois je
ne sais pas comment les infirmières les
enseignants les agents des impôts vont
réagir mais l'insee catégorique
en 1989 le salaire net moyen a plus
rapidement augmenté dans la fonction
publique que dans le secteur privé
la comparaison est elle pour autant
al'avantage du secteur public
réponse de marie claire tiers en 1989
les salaires nets moyens dans la
fonction publique ont augmenté dans une
fourchette comprise entre 4,7 pour cent
et 5,4 alors que dans le privé la
fourchette se situe entre 3,4 et 4 pour
une inflation de 3,6 pour cent des
chiffres qui seront affinées dans les
semaines qui viennent
les salaires moyens du secteur public
ont donc progressé plus vite que dans le
secteur privé
deux explications d'une part des mesures
générales tous les fonctionnaires ont
reçu en novembre
une prime exceptionnelle de croissance
de 1200 francs
d'autre part des mesures spécifiques
comme l'effort particulier fait pour
l'éducation nationale qui s'est traduit
sous forme de primes ou d'accélération
de carrière ou d'attribution de points
d'un 10 pour les instituteurs par
exemple c'est donc l'augmentation de ses
revenus autres que le traitement de base
qui a été plus importante dans le
secteur public que dans le secteur privé
et qui a fait toute la différence
le gouvernement de michel rocard a
désormais une épée de damoclès au dessus
de sa tête et cette épée à la forme
d'une faucille ou d'un marteau le parti
communiste pourrait en effet voté la
motion de censure déposée par
l'opposition en tout cas il ne l'exclût
pas françoise roy à votre app à
l'aministie nom finit pas d'embarrasser
le monde politique la place du colonel
fabien a donc décidé de retenir jusqu'à
mercredi seulement jour du comité
central extraordinaire un vrai faux
suspense vrai suspense parce que le vote
ou le rejet dépend de l'attitude des 26
députés communistes s'ils votent avec la
droite
ils peuvent renverser le gouvernement
une telle situation ne s'est produit
qu'une fois sous la vème république pour
la réforme de l'élection du président de
la république faux suspense parce que
nul ne peut imaginer ne serait ce qu'un
instant que les communistes puissent
s'unir à la droite andré lajoinie a
affirmé que son groupe ne faciliterait
pas cette dérisoire opérations de la
droite et l'humanité en première page
parlait d'une motion de censure qui
n'aurait aucun effet pour s'opposer à
cette loi scélérate
quoi qu'il arrive tout est clair enfin
pour la place du colonel fabien
quel que soit le vote des députés
communistes personne ne sera dédouané ni
le gouvernement ni les socialistes bien
sûr ni la droite qui a permis de la
faire passer cette fameuse loi
réponse mercredi dans la soirée pas de
commentaire de françois mitterrand sur
la situation politique actuelle
difficile pour lui l'occasion était
pourtant rêver le chef de l'état était
reçue par les journalistes à bordeaux et
françois mitterrand a préféré commenter
notre situation celle de la liberté de
la presse pour le président de la
république
le quatrième pouvoir doit réfléchir à
ses responsabilités reportage à bordeaux
bernard gonna accueil chaleureux du
président françois mitterrand à bordeaux
pour l'ouverture de la 39ème assemblée
générale de l'institut international de
la presse devant 500 congressistes venus
de 70 pays la plupart journalistes et
personnalités politiques françois
mitterrand a réaffirmé dans son discours
inaugural que la liberté de la presse
était indissociable de la démocratie
tout en rendant un hommage vivant
quant aux journalistes morts en mission
partout dans le monde à berlin à prague
est plus calme enfin la liste serait
longue des capitales d'europe pour
l'ajouter au siam pékin ou même à bogota
les journalistes ont été au coeur des
luttes contre la telma tolérance et
contre l'arbitré parole libre
information libre
jeauneau libre on a partout entendu le
même cri enfin le président de la
république a mis l'accent sur le pouvoir
des médias et sur leurs responsabilités
en matière d'éthique et il a appelé les
journalistes à prendre le parti de la
qualité et à ne pas surenchérir droit
après tout on peut le dire comme ça
entre nous
le sens le sexe le crime sont de
puissantes drogue excite l'envi et la
curiosité
ils constituent aussi de puissants
arguments commerciaux
après son allocution d'ouverture
françois mitterrand en a profité pour
s'entretenir avec le chancelier
d'autriche franz vranitzky ici ainsi
qu'avec le ministre des affaires
étrangères tchéco slovaque jiri
dienstbier pierre louis blanc bonsoir on
dit que françois mitterrand a des
difficultés parce qu'il est au pouvoir
depuis neuf ans bientôt dix ans est-ce
que dix ans et fatidique pour pour un
chef d'état
c'est une longue durée de pouvoir mais
le général de gaulle à gouverner
beaucoup plus longtemps alors vous y
vous additionnez les sacs à mener qui
vont de 1940 à 1945 et les dix années
qui vont de 1958 à 1969 ça fait 15 ans
tué mes difficultés au bout des dix
années 58 69 points 0
alors on vous a invité parce que vous
êtes l'auteur d'un livre de gaulle au
soir de sa vie publier chez fayard et on
vous a invité parce que le 19/20 donnent
le coup d'envoi de la nuit la plus
longue organisé par jacques chancel le
directeur des programmes de la 3 et
marcel jullian cent ans après la
naissance du général de gaulle et vous
étiez un collaborateur très proche le
secrétaire du général de gaulle oui j'ai
travaillé trois ans par le goal deux ans
à l'elysée et un an après j'allais le
voir à titre personnel à colombes est
alors votre titre est explicite au soir
de sa vie que se passait-il au soir de
sa vie vous que l'approché que vous dit
il il écrivait ses mémoires
essentiellement c'est tout ce qu'il m'a
dit il m'a surtout dit à l'occasion de
la rédaction de ses mémoires et il m'a
dit aussi un soin font d'autres choses
oui quand le lire dans votre dans votre
livre de gaulle est mort peu de temps
après la défaite de 1969
est ce que cette défaite politique a
accentué le déclin physique ça je ne
crois pas ça il faudrait il faut se
demander un médecin mais je ne crois pas
parce que moi j'ai toujours vu un homme
tout à fait au meilleur de sa forme
intellectuellement intacte parfaitement
lucide comme il avait toujours été ce
que je crois bien sûr c'est que il a été
il était pas il était serein je forme de
sa vie
il était peut-être pas très heureux on a
dit que le référendum c'était une sorte
de suicide politique
il voulait sans la mer anciennement ça
je ne prends pas ça je ne pense pas je
ne prends pas la théorie
suicide politique il reste derrière des
guerriers et il a été actif il était une
extraordinaire activité est majeur en
appel ce un détail on allait se promener
parfois dans le parc de la boisserie et
j'avais des difficultés à le suivre
tellement il marchait d'un pas l'air à
mythifier ça d'une agente pas du tout
média social moi je suis assez solide
donc je sais pas où il était c'est un
homme qui est entré dans la mort intacte
comment réagirait-il aujourd'hui
danseuse dans ce tourbillon
international savez c'est dit il c'est
dire moi je vous réponds que toutes les
fois qu'on me dit que ferait de bol je
dis très simplement je n'en sais rien et
je vais vous dire pourquoi
c'était un homme de diagnostic
c'était un homme de réflexion c'était un
homme d'observation politique et il se
il se crée progressivement il se dégager
dans un esprit une idée globale la
situation et je pense ce qu'on peut dire
mais je ne sais pas ce que ça aurait été
je pense qu'il aurait eu une idée de ce
qu'était monsieur gorbatchev
je pense qu'ils auraient vu qu'elle est
l évolution possible la politique
monsieur gorbatchev etc etc je le pense
pour les gens et pour ne parler que de
notre pays comment réagirait-il face à
la montée de l'extrême droite en un mot
c'est un homme qui n'a jamais été
partisan de l'extrêmement élise sept
jours de visite officielle pour jean
paul ii au mexique le pape est arrivé
hier mexico et chose étonnante dans un
pays réputé anti clérical le président
carlos salinas a fait un pas vers le
saint père il tente apparemment de
normaliser ses rapports avec le vatican
classé bastille un accueillant le saint
père à sa descente d'avion
le président de la république mexicaine
carlos salinas a créé la surprise
pour sa deuxième visite au mexique la
mission de jean paul ii devait être
exclusivement pastorale le mexique
n'entretenant pas de relations
diplomatiques avec le vatican
pourtant la tentation était forte pour
le président de normaliser les rapports
avec rome dans un pays où 90% de la
population est catholique calcul
politique ou pas les mexicains eux
furent très nombreux à saluer le
saint-père dans les rues de mexico très
nombreux aussi dans la basilique de
guadalupe jean paul ii qu'on célèbre sa
première messe en terre mexicaine
une messe au cours de laquelle le
souverain pontife a béatifié quatre
indiens mexicains ayant vécu au xvième
siècle parmi lesquels juan diego a qui
est apparue en 431 la vierge noire de
guadalupe la deuxième visite de jean
paul ii au mexique en 1979 il avait
inauguré sa série de voyages en amérique
latine par un premier contact avec le
peuple mexicain
aucun président de la république n'était
alors venus l'accueillir
mais la ferveur des fidèles était dit-on
ce jour là bien plus grande
lors de sa visite hier le pape a rappelé
son soutien mikhaïl gorbatchev il
approuve toujours la pérestroïka mais
jean paul ii a tenu aussi à rappeler les
droits des peuples il s'exprimait bien
sûr propos de l'indépendance de la
lituanie le pape a une nouvelle fois
prenez le drake le dialogue et cet appel
au dialogue lancé par le pape et par les
autres dirigeants occidentaux pourraient
être entendus le kremlin ne semble pas
vouloir condamner brutalement l'attitude
de riga il demande simplement une
clarification de la part des autorités
mais cette demande pourrait ne pas être
satisfaite le nouveau premier ministre
est semble-t-il très obstiné portrait
par nos envoyés spéciaux
joseph tual et hélène risacher ivars
godmanis
être élu premier ministre de lettonie
indépendantistes du front populaire il
comme la transition douce dans les
tendances complet avec des formes
économiques par étapes pour éviter le
chômage et l'inflation priorité établir
des relations privilégiées avec les
autres pays baltes et développer des
relations directes avec les républiques
soviétiques
d'abord négocié avec moscou il faut
retourner en arrière c'est impossible
renoncer à notre déclaration
d'indépendance du 4 mai ça voudrait dire
réunira parlement refaire tout non
lorsque ne peut pas mettre cette
condition comme préalable à toute
discussion
il n'y a qu'une solution c'est cette
indépendance et nous ne changeront
jamais notre déclaration
j'en suis sûr à 100% pas de retour en
arrière mais l'avenir immédiat s'annonce
difficile
la lettonie subi une greffe une économie
en ce moment à riga la pénurie d'essence
est telle que les voitures restent au
garage
les taxis qui marchent gaz se font
attendre 2 à 4 heures en banlieue les
restaurants fermés ce soir aux deux
clients
cette pénurie est due au blocus
économique de moscou contre la lituanie
voisine qui normalement fourni du
pétrole les temps nous pensons c'est un
blocus économique de moscou contre nous
serait un non sens car par effet de
boomerang ça risque de mettre en péril
aussi des entreprises soviétique pour
l'instant moscou nous a demandé des
informations sur notre déclaration
d'indépendance
c'est plutôt une bonne chose nous allons
envoyer ces documents et dans les jours
qui viennent donc délégation de lettonie
malgré l'ampleur de la tâche qui les
attend les nouveaux responsables de
lettonie font preuve ce soir d'optimisme
sur de leurs droits ils attendent la
réaction officielle de moscou
l'amérique attend toujours la libération
de nouveaux otages mais la maison
blanche tient à démentir les rumeurs il
n'y aura pas de négociations avec les
ravisseurs
quelques heures plus tôt l'ex otage
franco creed lors d'une conférence de
presse bouleversante avait pourtant
longuement expliqué ses conditions de
détention un véritable calvaire
d'après ses déclarations frank reid
aurait en effet été brutalisés tout au
long de sa détention on écoute tout de
suite son témoignage
en france il y a de l'orage dans l'air
michel tour et vous le confirmera à
19h57 mais il faut s'en réjouir et prier
pour que le ciel pleuvent sur le tête
en aquitaine la sécheresse est déjà
catastrophique pourtant les eaux
souterraines ne sont pas assez utilisés
encore inexploitées le forage profond
des nappes phréatiques pourrait être
l'une des solutions pour lutter contre
la sécheresse seul problème cette
technique est assez coûteuse reportage à
faire 3 bordeaux signé aurillac
la sécheresse n'est pas une fatalité
c'est ce que l'on ne cesse d'affirmer
depuis quelques semaines au bureau de
recherches géologiques et minières
selon cet organisme en france les nappes
profondes ne sont pas suffisamment
utilisé et pourtant actuellement elle
contiendrait mille milliards de mètres
cubes d'eau et sur ces 1000 milliards
seulement 7 serait prélevée chaque année
parmi les régions les mieux pourvus
l'aquitaine paradoxalement l'une des
régions qui souffrent le plus de la
sécheresse est celle qui possède aussi
un des plus gros réservoir d'eau du pays
l'aquitaine de prêts très grosses
réserves d'eau souterraines très
importante avec des nappes profondes
notamment de d'excellente qualité ce qui
n'est pas du tout le cas dans certains
départements voisins et en particulier
du midi pyrénées où il n'y a
pratiquement pas de ressources
or des vallées de la garonne cela dit en
aquitaine on commence à tirer les leçons
du passé
après la succession de sécheresse ces
dernières années des forages profonds
été effectués notamment en dordogne unis
cinq ans en dordogne nous on assiste à
des procédés des projets annuel de
l'ordre d'une dizaine de forage nouveau
les styles et à l'eau potable
essentiellement reste qu'un forage
profond d'exploitation dos cela coûte
très cher plus de 2 millions de francs à
ce niveau de financement le choix est
donc politique
en tout cas selon le bureau de
recherches géologiques et minières
mieux vaut prévenir que guérir les
nappes souterraines ne sont pas assez
exploitées il faut donc agir vite sans
se contenter d'attendre simplement le
traditionnel impôt sécheresse
un télégramme à l'instant de new york le
tribunal international vient de rendre
son jugement dans la sphère du rainbow
warrior
il a rejeté la demande néo zélandaise
exigent le retour sur une base militaire
française du pacifique
l'atoll de hao du commando alain mafart
et du capitaine dominique prieur mais il
demande à la france de verser 2
lyon de dollars environ 12 millions de
francs un fonds franco néo zélandais qui
serait créé et je cite pour encourager
les relations amicales et étroite entre
les citoyens des deux pays
jugement de salomon s'il meurt dans un
dramatique accident de la route près de
poitiers voici tout de suite les autres
faits marquants de l'actualité en france
grâce aux images de nos stations
régionales comme en terre and go
l'accident le plus sanglant du week-end
s'est produit ici sur cette route
forestière tranquille de saint georges
les baillargeaux dans la vienne un
accident qui a fait six morts et deux
blessés graves
âgées de 14 à 23 ans et deux voitures
qui circulaient dans le même sens sont
entrés en collision lorsque le premier
producteur a perdu le contrôle pour une
raison inconnue
par les îles trafic des car ferries avec
la corse depuis hier les marins du
syndicat des travailleurs corses sont en
grève
il réclame trois emplois supplémentaires
sur le bateau ile de beauté qui a été
agrandie de 20 mètres les 300 passagers
bloqués sur l'île ou dut rejoindre
marseille dans des avions affrétés par
la société nationale corse méditerranée
la fête a viré au drame samedi soir mais
près de melun
l'acce pivotant d'un manège s'est
déboîté avant l'arrêt complet projetant
quatre personnes à terre trois enfants
ont été légèrement blessés dans
l'accident et un adulte est dans un état
grave
trois classes d'une école maternelle ont
été pillés et incendiés hier soir à
cannes et dans la banlieue toulousaine
un acte de vandalisme sans doute commis
par des enfants il a fallu une heure aux
pompiers pour maîtriser le sinistre
les deux retardataires du globe
challenge rentrer au bercail guy
bernardin éliminé pour s'être arrêtée en
tasmanie à court d'une rage de dents et
en idées aux sables d'olonne ce midi
classé septième et dernier jean françois
coste est attendu contre lui demain dans
la journée fin de ce 19 20 mai début de
la nuit la plus longue sur fr3 cent ans
après la naissance du général de gaulle
et 45 ans après la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale cette nuit commencera
avec une émission spéciale dans quelques
minutes à 20h05
avec pierre andré boutang philipe de
saint et claude jean philippe
elle se poursuivra à 20h45 avec un film
de marcel pagnol l'affût la fille du
puisatier avec notamment raimu et
fernandel
le prochain rendez vous avec
l'information c'est soir 3 à 23h05
présentée par marc hautement tout de
suite la météo complète de missiles
touré bonsoir à demain 19h bonsoir